- They had me.
They had the door locked behind me
and they were keeping me against my will.
(ping pong ball bouncing)
There's so much inside me that's broken
and damaged from all of this.
(slow instrumental music)
- [Worker] A lot of times we did admit who
didn't necessarily need
inpatient level of treatment
but we were encouraged to
admit as many people as possible.
(slow instrumental music)
We were really encouraged to
kinda make a story
that sometimes looked more severe
on paper than it probably actually was.
- I made the comment
you know, it's Texas, it's
not that hard to find a gun.
Never in my wildest dreams
would I have imagined that joking comment
would be the absolute
crux of why they thought
they were going to hold
me against my will.
I was walked down a long hallway
where you normally see what I
thought was doctor's offices,
and they weren't, but
it was hospital rooms.
At that point,
I realized something wasn't right.
I kept saying, I'd like to access,
I'd like a second opinion,
I'd like to leave.
I mean, I called the police,
I asked them to let me go,
to let the police officers
see the paperwork.
They wouldn't tell them anything,
they wouldn't tell me anything.
(slow instrumental music)
They take you out of your life
and they hold you like a prisoner,
like a criminal.
- [Worker] It did kinda
seem like a trap at times
Most people didn't know
what they were coming into.
(slow instrumental music)